awareness and predicted multiplicity say
hi everyone uh thanks for coming back
from lunch for this and today I'm going
to talk about two things one is on
limits of group awareness and another is
on predictive multiplicity you'll learn
what that is about in a bit
um the work that I'm going to talk about
today was done by an amazing group of
collaborators and students a very
photogenic group including shahab and
hewan who presented here how sean well
Lucas and Carol and Juan Felipe who are
graduate students in my group and
Winston and Lucy who are undergrads at
Harvard College
data-driven algorithms are increasingly
used to support decision making in
applications of individual level
consequence we heard about this earlier
in sangameters talk a lot of machine
learning algorithms are using in
applications that can really affect
people's lives things like loan approval
medicine
education and so on and there's been a
growing call in developing these
algorithms in a responsible manner um a
lot of the the of this sentiment is
captured in the latest blueprint for an
AI Bill of Rights put forward by the
White House by the White House Office of
Science and Technology where they
suggest that one of our rights in terms
of AIA is protection against algorithmic
discrimination namely you should not
face discrimination by algorithms and
systems should be used and designed in
an equitable Equitable way
and this problem this challenge of um
designing non-discriminatory algorithms
is something that my group has been
thinking about for a while particularly
from the theory perspective and this is
a really hard problem
um I wanted to show this this is a daily
generated picture under the prompt a
photorealistic multifaceted polyphilian
against the white background it's
surprisingly good and I wanted to show
this because this problem of developing
Fair machine learning algorithms
protection against discrimination is a
problem that has many many facets
there's not one definition or one aspect
of fairness to rule them all there are
many different facets through this
problem and lately we've been working on
three of these facets one is group
fairness which I'll be talking about
today another one is predictive
multiplicity that I'll talk about as
well and another one is fair use of data
um this is something that I won't have
time to talk about today but you can ask
me later and recently in the past year
year and a half my group has been uh
having a few results in exploring this
area and today I'm going to be talking
about this stream of work on predictive
multiplicity that dates back to HTML
2020 and also some recent results on
group fairness
so did you start off I'm going to start
talking a little bit about
um group fairness and specifically the
limits of group fairness um there will
be something that looks like a Converse
bound towards the end of this section of
the talk so uh information theorists
hold on to your hats and um so just you
set the stage this is a setting that
we're considering we have a data set and
from this data set we have a sample X
and we're going to fit this sample to a
classifier for example neural network
that's going to Output some output h of
X this might be a score a distribution
over classes and so on and what we're
trying to ensure here is and what we'll
be looking at at this first part is
something known as group reference the
challenge that we're trying to ensure is
that we're trying to address is that
classifier performance should not change
significantly across population groups
what I mean by classifier performance
I'll be a little bit more specific about
this uh in a few slides what I mean by
that is things like accuracy false
positive rate and false negative rate
shouldn't change across the groups in
the data set so condition on these
groups the performance of the classifier
shouldn't change significantly and what
I mean by population groups is exactly
what is encapsulated here in the
blueprint for an AI Bill of Rights these
are groups that are determined by race
color ethnicity sex or other attributes
or intersection of these attributes
and in this case many group fairness
metrics have been proposed um the group
fairness metrics are usually cast in
terms of these quantities here I'm going
to introduce just a little bit more
notation so we have an input example X
denoted as a random variable x uh
classifier h of X that's going to
produce an output y of hat this is also
a random variable if x is a random
variable and we have these group
attributes s this is a collection of
discrete attributes that are going to
use to evaluate model performance and
within this notation there are many
group fairness that we can build upon
this
um in the simplest case where your what
you're predicting is binary or
predicting a binary label and your group
attribute is binary as well in that case
the way you can build group fairness
Matrix is the following um you know you
can build a confusion Matrix for
population zero and a confusion Matrix
for a population one for this true
binary populations this is the simplest
case and by comparing entries in this
major and these two matrices you can
Define different fairness metrics so for
example if you're trying to equalize the
outcomes um second ritual mentioned
about this earlier you're trying to
ensure statistical parity so the
fractions of outputs marked as one is
approximately the same across different
groups if you're trying to equalize
false positive and true positive rates
you have a notion that's called
equalized odds but you can already see
that just by comparing entries of this
Matrix or for its extension for multiple
classes this confusion matrices for
multiple groups there are many many
other metrics and trade-offs that you
can Define
um on this table
and the way and so there are many
fairness interventions that have been
proposed that try to ensure some notion
of group fairness or preserving accuracy
and the way that these different
interventions are compared and their
performance is benchmarked is through
graphs that look like this you can't
really see the the grid lines because of
the lighting
um but this is a result from a no uh
fairly old in machine learning years
paper uh by Sir by Sarah friedler's
group at Haverford College where they
compared at the time in 2019 several
fairness interventions but I wanted to
show this just to illustrate how these
methods are benchmarked and compared
usually you have graphs that look like
this where on the x-axis you have
something that is a fairness metric in
this case it looks like statistical
parity on the y-axis you have accuracy
and for different data sets you you try
to see how these methods fare in terms
of accuracy fairness performance and as
I mentioned there's been many group
fairness interventions out there this is
a recent um survey that was posted a few
months back on the archive by heart at
all where they highlight over 340
everyone Publications suggesting
fairness interventions which amount to
over 400 fairness interventions that
exist in the literature that have been
uh published recently and I'm certainly
responsible for a few of these
Publications and we're going to talk
about one more method today as well and
in general these methods can be divided
into three groups right you can think
about them as pre-processing where you
change the data prior to feeding it to
the to the to the model in processing
and highlighting your work by Ahmed a
very nice uh pre-processing in
processing technique that was recently
published at tmlr or post-processing
methods right you just strain your
classifiers you usually would and then
you you you change you change its
predictions in order to ensure some good
fairness metrics as I mentioned I'm
responsible for some of these methods as
well
um just recently we proposed a method
called Fair projection I won't have time
to go into details on this but I just
wanted to give you a high level overview
of how it works where we're trying to
where our goal was to design yet another
fairness intervention but that ensured
fairness for large data sets and a
multiple class prediction problems so
not only for binary classes and could uh
ensure fairness also for multiple groups
and there are many fairness
interventions out there but what we've
found is that many of them have certain
limitations most of them either are only
benchmarked on fairly small data sets or
they only scale to small data sets for
example they might require retraining
them all multiple times or they only
consider binary classification or only
ensure fairness for binary groups
so um my point and where I'm going to
next is to show how these um to try to
ask and answer the question of what is
the best performance that these methods
can achieve but we did propose a method
called for projection that overcomes
these limitations they can be used for
any number of classes and protected
groups as long as you have sufficient
samples we Benchmark it on fairly large
data sets just over a million samples
and it can be applied to any classifier
without retraining Fair projection is a
post-processing method that you can
apply to basically any classifier and
um again I'm not going to go through the
details and because this is based on an
optimization problem very similar to
information projection
um that you already know from your
information three classes you usually
you'll find this when you're studying
error exponents and so on and um we
spent a lot of time working on this
method and it's based on tilting that
model's output in order to ensure a
given group fairness metrics you can
implement it using an ADM based
algorithm a similar in spirit to a
thought presented this morning actually
and it runs on GPU we have available
code for that and well presented it
yesterday so if you didn't stop by his
poster shame on you you should have
stopped by it was a great poster and and
you can find more details in our
uh our paper but the point that I wanted
you to talk about this with you today
is because of these results
so um we spent a lot of time engineering
this method and we went and benchmarked
it on different data sets and again
these are the same plots that we saw
earlier on where you on the x-axis you
have a notion of group fairness meaning
equalized lots and on the y-axis you
have accuracy right you're looking at
the performance uh of the model average
across the entire population and these
are our benchmarks I just want to
highlight this data set if you're
interested in this area or testing
fairness interventions this is a data
set that we did not produce but we
translated it through English based on
the University entrance exam in Brazil
with over 1 million samples that really
allows you to this is open source data
made available by the Brazilian
government that really allows you to
stress test a lot of these algorithms
and um hsls is another data set that he
won mentioned on on Monday in addition
travel and Compass which are usual data
sets in this field and what we do here
is that
um this star here represents our
Baseline classifier so if you just train
a random forest model and evaluate its
accuracy and what fairness odds it
achieves it's up here it's very accurate
but there's quite a bit of disparity in
performance and our method here in dark
red is for projection and you can see
it's really competitive with methods
that are out there the other one that's
as competitive as ours is the reductions
approach which is tailored for binary
classification but it's an in-processing
method that requires retraining a model
many many many times so it doesn't
really scale up in large data sets like
the nem we have over 100x gain in speed
because of this parallelization inherent
through the admm algorithm but what I
want you to keep in mind here is that
you can see that there seems to be
diminishing returns right so we
Benchmark these methods across different
data sets and they perform almost the
same right they have very very similar
performance in this Pareto Frontier
between fairness and accuracy and so
um if you Benchmark this in multi-class
classification task surprisingly even
though there are hundreds of fairness
interventions out there at the time that
we wrote this paper we only found one
that worked for multi-class
classification and was this American and
unwanted biases with adversarial
learning uh by Zhang at all and our
method also performs very competitively
yeah that's not quite correct okay so we
you can challenge me afterwards and if
you know a method for that ensures good
fairness for multi-class classification
oh no no I'm not I'm not claiming it's
post-processing I'm just claiming that
it it works with multiple classes all
right so um but the question that I want
to arrive is is what is the best
fairness accuracy Frontier right because
if you look at these plots there seems
to be a diminishing returns phenomena
here right you're over engineering these
methods and it would be nice to have
something that looks like a Converse
result stating that for a given it is an
obviously under certain assumptions on
the data distribution and so on can we
argue that there is a non-achievable
region can we design a Converse result
and show that we're really really close
to that and I guess this has been a
trend in a lot of the talks today but
since I'm at Berkeley shout out to David
Blackwell because we're going to use
exactly his data processing result on
comparison of experiments in order to
delineate something that looks like a
Converse result that allows us to
compare these methods against what will
be the ideal information theoretic best
so that's what I'm going to do next is
is it is it clear I'm going to be
talking about what is this Converse
result here so
let's return to the setting that we had
earlier so just to refresh your memory
on notation so we have these group
attributes s that denotes membership to
on a given group we have this label why
that's a true outcome that we use to
train the model but in practice it's not
observed when you deploy it your input
example X and your classifier h of X for
example a neural network or something of
the the sorry
and this uh forms a Markov chain like
this right from s and Y you feed it to x
x may include s you may use this as an
in particular classifier and you're
going to and your classroom is going to
generate an output YF hat there's this
markup of relationship here and we're
going to assume that the joint
distribution between s y and x is fixed
we usually don't know this distribution
but for the purpose of Designing a
Converse result we're interested in that
it's fixed
now ideally
um if we could do something like this if
we could characterize the set of all
distributions and if we move at the
distribution between s y and x and we
could characterize the set of all
mappings from X to Y hat we could
potentially characterize this well
actually in this case it would
characterize exactly what is the optimal
parental Frontier between accuracy and
fairness we could try to solve this
optimization problem where we find the
best distribution between y hat and S
and Y given the constraints posed by
this markup relationship in order to
maximize accuracy and uh controlling
some a given fairness metric and so this
is what we're going to do next our goal
is to find simple ways of characterizing
the set of distributions so we can plug
this into this optimization problem and
plot something that looks like the
optimal Pareto Frontier where we can
Benchmark existing method methods
against that
so I'm going to show how we did this
through a cartoon
so you can think about the set of all
mappings from syhy hat as this blue set
here so this is the set of all
conditional distributions
um in the case that S Y and Y hat are
binary this is the set of four by two
matrices that are row stochastic
matrices
and if you choose one machine learning
model that you deploy in practice you're
inducing one point in this space right
because that will uh in this one mapping
from s and Y to Y hats M for which you
can then evaluate fairness and accuracy
and so on
um of course you have constraints to the
problem posed by the generate data
generating process and that restricts
the set of achievable conditional
distributions given these constraints
here denoted here by this orange set
here and as I mentioned before our goal
is that um it's true characterize the
best fairness accuracy Frontier and most
fairness and accuracy metrics can be
cast in terms of this joint distribution
remember the table that I drew earlier
where we had confusion Matrix for group
zero and confusion Matrix for group one
that's exactly calcium fairness metric
in terms of properties of this joint
distribution here so if we could
characterize
um uh since so if we could characterize
this uh we could characterize the set
that gives the best information
throughout the frontier which is exactly
this set here so the challenges in doing
this is first
um obviously that the data distributions
are unknown so we don't know that in
practice we only access that from their
samples but even then we could relax
that to create what I'm going to show
next synthetic experiments to Benchmark
existing methods but the other
challenges that these input features X
might be actually quite High dimensional
and these constraints for example
equalizing true positive rates and post
positive rates there are non-convex
integer constraints that are very hard
to deal with
so um so in order to address the second
point the key idea that we have is
instead of trying to characterize this
set exactly we're going to create a
bound on this set that's more
computationally tractable right the
simpler bound because then if we solve
this
um this optimization problem over this
outer set here what we get is an upper
Bound for the resolving the optimization
over a larger set so we get an upper
Bound for the best fairness accuracy
Frontier
and just your true as a warm-up of how
you could do something like that is that
you could constraint a set of
distributions using something like the
data processing inequality right so if
you're giving them much information
between S Y and Y hat we know that that
much information cannot be greater than
the mutual information between s y and x
and imposing this one constraint on this
set already restricts the set of all
possible distributions that you can
achieve uh the challenge here is that
this amount might be very very loose
right it's not even clear of mutual
information is the right metric so and
this is where Blackwell comes in and we
use Blackwell's result of comparison of
experiments because this result gives
you a precise characterization of data
processing right that we have this Con
that this markup condition holds only FP
of x given Sy is more informative than P
of Y hat given s y and you can write
this very precisely in terms of this
theorem here so this is Blackwell serum
that given a taking values in N for any
two distributions we have x given a and
b of Z given a you can create these uh
things that look like these likely good
vectors and you see that b of x given a
is more informative than Q of Z given a
if for any convex function Phi this
expectation on P is greater equal than
the expectation of the sync function
measured according to q and you can
already squint at this and see that if I
pick this convex function should be
something that looks like V log V also a
context function you recover something
that resembles the data processing
inequality from Mutual information but
you can choose any convex function here
and the one that we choose our piecewise
linear functions to try to approximate
the set of achievable joint
distributions and in fact a black hole
shows that in general this is sufficient
so this problem of choosing convex
functions that we're going to use to
bounce the set of achievable
um distributions this can be formulated
as an optimization problem a problem
that's the difference of convex
optimization functions of the difference
of convex functions and we can optimize
for that and find successive Cuts uh
these near functions to approximate this
set and once we have this approximation
we can solve this optimization or try to
approximate this uh this optimization
over this restricted set and that will
give us an outer bound yes
they're not necessarily tangent because
we're not solving it exactly I'm not
going into the details here but like
we're solving it using yeah so it won't
necessarily be Gadget yeah
but you're always on the outside you're
always on the outside because you can
pause this as a constraint to the
optimization
um that you satisfied so it is about
here so they're always on the outside
but you're not necessarily touching that
set
how are you doing like what kind of work
no and we we formulated it as a
difference of convex uh difference of
comics functions that we successfully
successively keep like finding these
these Cuts so let me show you the
results of how this works
so what did British show next are
semi-synthetic experiments where we
assume that the data set is the ground
truth so what we do is that we did one
of these usual data sets and we we
sample from it with replacement
um and use that to train and test our
fairness interventions and it's kind of
an approximation because it shows that
because we assume that the actual data
set is the ground truth and then we
apply this method to create this uh
outer bound and compare it uh to the
fairness interventions against that and
this is where we're at
so these are results for the adult data
set uh and the the red line here is the
frontier that we call it it's the result
of this optimization problem and we
repeat this for Compass and for German
credit
and as you can see the reductions
approach uh and for projection are right
on the money like we're really really
close should be to the optimal Frontier
so this doesn't mean that if you try
this with different data sets and so on
it wouldn't be close but it means that
for these data sets that are widely used
in the literature there seems to be
diminishing returns and continuing to
propose the next hundred fairness
interventions that optimize solely for
fairness and accuracy so the takeaway
here is that it seems like we're close
to the information track optimal
fairness accuracy Frontier at least in
this these so much synthetic experiments
that we've done before read them
you know her computer shiny data set
well
um
in theory you can do it like there's
some issues with the optimization
problem uh that I we can discuss offline
yeah but I view this as a limitation
yeah
I actually interpreted differently what
I find we have a discussion on that in
the paper like because there's an um but
the way I interpret this is that the
optimization the fairness interventions
that we have out there they're already
really good at achieving this fairness
accuracy effect you're approximating it
like um the Remake this the main kind of
curve that we have we call that
um aliatoric discrimination which might
be biases that are inherent in the data
right and that might be due to the data
collection process and so on but uh
removing those biases the epistemic
limit that comes from your choice of
model your choice of fairness
intervention it seems like that Gap is
really close to zero
so
um so that motivates us to look at other
aspects of fairness as well like so
because there seems to be diminishing
returns and continuing optimizing for
fairness and accuracy and now I want you
to talk about another problem that we've
been looking at called predictive
Multiplicity
so in order to introduce predictive
multiplication I need to talk about the
rational effect and which I'm going to
talk about next so consider again the
problem of fitting a machine learning
model where I have a set of samples say
x-ray images and I'm going to fit in
your network in order to predict some
label from this image this this model is
parameterized by some parameter Theta
and um let's say you're predicting if
this imager this just x-ray has
pneumonia or not during training time
um you have to make a ton of decisions
prior to training in order to initialize
this process right you're going to set
the random seed to initialize how you're
going to initialize your weights you're
going to set Dropout rates uh shuffle
your batches and all that stuff let's
call that different random
initializations
and as you vary these arbitrary choices
these random initializations you're you
might after training you might end up
with a different model and these models
when you evaluate them many of them
might achieve very similar performance
basically during empirical loss might be
below a given threshold they're the loss
that they achieve
um this phenomena where you have
multiple uh distinct models with
comparable performance for a given
learning task is known as the rashimon
effect it was
um as far as I know first identified by
Leo bryman um nearby at Stanford and
it's the name rashmon comes from Akira
kurozawa a 1950s movie rashmon where
different people report the same crime
from different perspectives and give
different explanations of what happens
and this parameter Epsilon here is what
we call the rashimon parameter it
determines like the size of the set of
competing models and we have a result
that we're going to be talking about at
isit this year where this Epsilon you
can already see this that it will always
be non-zero if you're evaluating your
model on a finite data set so there's
always an inherent uncertainty a
confidence interval up to which you can
know the performance of your model and
within that uncertainty that confidence
interval you might have just by
perturbing the weights of a model you
might generate many different competing
models
so you can think about this rational
effect as almost creating these islands
in our model space especially if your
model is your hypothesis face if this
space is not a convex where you have
multiple uh competing good models models
that satisfy their average performance
is below a given threshold so that's a
rashamon effect
um so what when we're predictive
multiplicity comes in is when you look
at the perform the predictions of these
models for one individual sample so you
have these multiple competing models
that based on accuracy alone you can't
distinguish them but when you feed one
sample to these models they might
produce conflicting predictions so um
and this example for different
um for example for this x-ray image uh
different models might give different
incidents of pneumonia
um rate and that's what we called
predictive multiplicity in a in a paper
an icml 2020. and as far as we can
double predictive multiplicity occurs in
many learning tasks so we've founded an
image classification problems or you can
find samples that have this conflict
across competing classifiers and text
classification and audio classification
and so on and predictable um yeah
sure here discuss in these examples the
classifiers were generated via
retraining these are neural networks
um and we just retrain them with
different random initialization same
data set and ended up with different
models but with different random
initializations
um sorry so you were saying that the
expected loss is different from the
individual no the expected loss is
similar average yeah but but certain
individual predictions May conflict
meaning that they're different they're
different
and why this is surprising so I'm not
saying it's surprising but I'll shoot
yeah yeah well they don't agree but but
I can tell you why this is important
um the reason why this is important is
because the predictable multiplicity is
not accounted for
um in practice decision supported by
Machine learning models may depend on
arbitrary and unjustified choices to
make during training so if someone might
be using the model and think that this
prediction is due to the features that
I'm using as an input to the model but
they're actually due to some choice of
random seed made prior to model
development and this is particular like
this is an argument made by Creole and
Hellman and a paper in the Virginia law
review that particularly in sectors
dominated by a few algorithms like this
has a risk of creating these algorithmic
Leviathan so these are
um because of these arbitrary choices
and if these algorithms control access
to critical opportunities you might be
excluding certain individuals from these
opportunities let me give you one
example uh one is uh from the Brazilian
government who actually announced a year
ago that they're going to use AI to
grade the handwritten essay component of
the University entrance exam in Brazil
this is an exam that I took the ending
exam and they're going to be using
machine learning models to give grades
through essays and of course for some
students you don't want the grade for
that essay to depend on some random seed
you should initialize your convolutional
neural network the folks who are
developing this by the way are at The
Graduate School of Education at Harvard
and like some of the researchers doing
this another example is Spike will
scores and credit scoring right these
are algorithms that control access to
critical opportunities loans right and
if you want to get a loan your data will
inevitably be fed to one of three
algorithms
so we explored this problem uh different
aspects of this problem and we should
talk about one result that we had
recently on how can we measure and
Report predicted multiplicity this is
based on an Europe's favor from last
year and um I'm just uh I'll just give
you a high level overview of this
because one issue that we face is how do
you even report this this conflict of
scores that exists among multiple models
given that you have some approximation
of this Russia monset so given an
individual sample and when you feed it
to competing models models with a
similar performance but particularly
multi-class classification problems you
will get conflicting predictions you can
think about this as the output of a
model over three classes where you say
with probability with 0.05 your class uh
one 90 or class two and a five percenter
class three
so um if you collect these conflicting
predictions these conflicting scores you
can collect them in a set that will
depend on your sample and on your
rational parameter Epsilon and create
the set of conflicting predictions and
the question that we ask is how should
we measure this car variation right how
should we point this to a user and
eventually build on this to measure this
multiplicity phenomena in practice so
our goal was to create a function that
would map this set into a number that
would capture this variation this
disagreement and score
and we wanted this function to
repostulate that this functions should
have certain desirable properties we
call this a multiplicity metric and it
should be between 1 and C so where one
means that there's no multiplicity and C
is the number of score of classes that
you're predicting so one means that all
of these predictions agree uh and you
want this value to be one if and only if
all of the predictions are the same you
want it to be C the number of classes
that you're predicting only if every
single class can be perfectly predicted
by some classifier in this Russian
monset and you want this set to be
monotonic in the sense that if you add
more scores to the set your your
multiplicity metric will not decrease
so
um we did this using actually
um information about tools from
information Theory uh we call this a one
we proposed one metric called rational
capacity and the key idea here is that
given a set of competing predictions for
a given sample we view each prediction
as the role of a noisy channel right so
each prediction is a probability
distribution over classes you can view
this as a role of a noisy Channel and
then you compute the capacity of this
channel and you can compute it in this
way right so this is not your usual way
of seeing Channel capacity this is a
more variational form usually you're
accustomed to C maximize Mutual
information over input distributions but
this is essentially the same thing where
you're finding a centroid in terms of
kale Divergence of these Computing
scores and maximizing over distributions
over models and note that this is a
metric that depends on each and for each
individual sample that depends on this
ration parameter here and the
multiplicity metric that we propose is
called rational capacity is this due to
the capacity and it's not difficult to
see this is a could be an exercise in an
information Theory class to show that it
satisfies all these desirable properties
so um rational capacity satisfies these
properties and you can compute it in
practice using the Blackwood remote
algorithm so in the few minutes that I
have left
um I want to talk a little bit also
about another recent paper and I
actually think this is really important
on a predictive multiplicity and
differential privacy and this is a paper
that we're going to be presenting that
fact in a few uh weeks
so consider again the setting that we
had where we're predicting uh given a
set of of
samples we're predicting say presence of
pneumonia and these x-ray images but
assume that now our our data is price as
price right this is privacy sensitive
data so one way of ensuring uh privacy
earn we already heard a lot about this
in this Workshop is that we can ensure
the PE using randomization during
training right so we can for example do
output perturbation what that means is
that you can perturb the the model
weights after training or you can use
objective perturbation again this is
based on Anonymous work where you add
some random perturbation to the
objective or you can do things like DP
SGD but I'm just going to collect all
these different strategies as using
Randomness during training
and
if you choose a given random C that you
initialize your random numbers uh
generator
um after training you're going to arrive
at a given model right a given set of
weights and with different
initializations you're going to have
different runs of your differentially
private algorithm and that's going to
lead the two different models at the end
and even though these competing models
they offer the same level of privacy
they can offer they can make conflicting
predictions through individual samples
and this conflict and predictions this
inconsistency in predictions is not
equally distributed across all samples
so some samples suffer more it does not
affect all samples equally and this is
something that's widely underreported
because you might use a differentially
private model and you think that well
this prediction is due to my features
but it might actually be an arbitrary
artifact of noise used during training
in order to ensure privacy and just to
give you a flavor of how this shows this
is an appears this is an example on
synthetic data where we train a logistic
regression classifier using objective
perturbation where we have random noise
through the objective in order to ensure
DP
um in this case we train 5000 models on
simple two-dimensional mixture of
gaussians and we only keep models that
have 80 accuracy of a baseline of course
you wouldn't do this in practice because
that would violate differential privacy
but this is what we're doing here and
what we report is disagreement that over
these 5000 uh 5000 runs what's the
probability that a given score would
change for a given sample and what You
observe is something like this so as
Epsilon increases this is not the same
Epsilon as the Russian said this is
Epsilon and Epsilon BP so higher Epsilon
is lower privacy and smaller apps on is
is higher privacy that um the the amount
of disagreement the probability that a
Scarborough changes does not impact all
the samples equally even though your
Baseline classifier the optimal one is
this 45 degree line query but always get
the same classifier if you train without
noise and we have many examples on this
uh on our paper I think the final
version actually was just posted on the
fact website and you can see again that
this effect of predictive multiplicity
does not affect each sample equally it's
not equally distributed across samples
and it's on equally distributed across
groups in the data you can see variation
of the incidence of this multiplicity
phenomena against groups determined by
age for example
so I'll wrap up here uh the takeaways is
that always measure and Report
predictive multiplication I think in
applications of individual level
consequence this is as important as
reporting test error multiplicity is a
hidden cost of differential privacy as
far as we can say and the folks that
reviewed our paper for facts said as
well that um this had not been
identified before uh decisions supported
by Machine learning models without
regard to multiplicity may seem
arbitrary right and there's still a ton
of open problems here we don't know how
to efficiently characterize the
structure on set nor report multiplicity
in a differentially private ensuring way
we we we're still exploring how to to do
that so
um I'll wrap up here I think my sponsors
and I'll be happy to answer any
questions thanks
[Applause]
oh okay so
DP could be looked at as another type of
parameter in this whole Space
how do you really tease out maybe in a
logistic model it was easy to do but how
do you tease out the effect of the other
parameters I think in the synthetic
example that I showed we only had like
if you train without privacy you only
have one optimal model so in this case
this Randomness comes entirely because
of this x that depend on each X right so
I don't remember if you had a lot of
like what how does what does that look
like over the over the chicken asset or
something I removed that plot because of
time but we can discuss here but what I
can say is that it depends on the
accuracy of your model but um in many
classifications especially in many uh
data sets especially in the image data
sets that we trained with like
neurometrics it's many local Minima
there tends to be a tail of samples of
high rational capacity so there tends to
be oh like something like 10 uh in in
cyber 10 or 15 of samples yeah and these
are not necessarily points that are in
your own decision boundary these could
be points that are simply outlined from
the data set is always
yeah
quite curious about how much
models not across retraining but across
over time because I saw this work that
showed that if you track a model over
time uh
yeah during training and you you ask its
prediction on individual points the
points that it uh did like oscillates on
or more likely are it's a good predictor
on mislabeling and this seems very
related to uh the VP point of like uh
um do you think there's a way to think
about this notion not just for uh many
different fitted models but just for a
single model in terms of like a
sensitivity analysis like how sensitive
the model is and somehow differentiate
that point
yeah that's that's such a good question
I was actually discussing the second
feature earlier is that um that is
related to the idea that she presented
counterfactuals right we're given given
that you might have an inherent
uncertainty a confidence interval in a
battery year model because you simply
have
um uh finite test data like if you just
for trip the weights of your model
around that point like which points are
the most sensitive like that's something
very extreme
[Applause]